[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen eichsfeld
und meine lieben freunde das ist
tatsächlich jetzt das letzte mal dass
ich diesen satz gesagt habe denn sie
sieht es bereits den titel heute ist das
große finale folge 100 100 folgen lang
war haben wir
ja dass ich nicht mal bei folge 100 ein
bisschen mitleid haben können 100 folgen
lang haben wir aus einer kleinen scheiß
insel eine wohlfühloase gemacht wir
haben eine strandhaus villa gebaut wir
haben einen unterwasser tunnel dahinten
baut eine skelette farm einen ballon
einen leuchtturm auf den ich am
stolzesten eigentlich bin ein portal
schwert eine verzauberung insel mein
haus hier hinten die willicher insel
deren dahin noch die trauer insel mit
der kirche hinten
[Musik]
wo kam denn jetzt her wir haben eine
menge also wirklich eine riesige menge
an dingen geschafft in diesem projekt es
ist einfach nur unfassbar was aus diesem
projekt geworden ist ich habe das ganze
projekt einfach nur gestartet weil ich
bock ab weil wieder auf minecraft hatte
weil ich ein bisschen in erinnerungen
gewählt bin und mir dachte er ich will
das ganze mal wieder spielen aber dass
das ganze projekt so durch die decke
geht dann hätte ich niemals gerechnet
und da bin ich einfach unfassbar stolz
und dankbar auch für euch deswegen meine
lieben freunde ich habe jetzt in der
folge 100 heute natürlich vor das ganz
projekt jetzt auch gehörig
klinge denn jetzt folge ein wunder durch
werde die anzahl von paketboten und
klippan gestört aber gute freunde ich
möchte auf jeden fall das projekt
minecraft mit luca zu einem glorreichen
ende bringen von daher werde ich mich
jetzt immer ein brötchen setzen und zu
unserem stronghold fahren denn das ist
der plan für heute ich möchte ins ende
gehen und ich möchte in ender drachen
besiegen oder erfahren wir noch ein
allerletztes mal hier durch das los
luxus schild durchschauen uns nochmal um
nach hinten und sehen unsere insel
[Musik]
für ein allerletztes mal für euch wird
das allerdings nicht das allerletzte mal
sein denn meine lieben freunde findet
jetzt schon unten in der video
beschreibung im download der map und den
zieht so dass ihr selbst euch diese
ganze welt nochmal anschauen könnt ihr
könnt euch auch wenn ihr wollt einfach
den zieht in minecraft eingeben dann
habt ihr nicht meine ganzen sachen die
ich gebaut habe sondern könnte meine
eigene welt nochmal von vorne spielen
ihr findet unter der beschreibung auf
einen link wo es diesen hoodie zu kaufen
gibt auf dem steht hinten auch nochmal
derzeit drauf und dieses wetter in
vintage zweiter den gibt es dort auch zu
kaufen die shop adresse müssten glaube
ich alle mittlerweile kämen
mich wird es auf jeden fall unfassbar
krass freuen wenn euch eines der beiden
teile also entweder dem blauen rudi oder
den vintage grünen sweater kaufen würde
ich habe ein jahr lang oder so kein
match mehr ausgebracht und bei denen
waffen haben uns wirklich eine menge
mühe gegeben sehr sehr sehr sehr geil
mit seinem papa print drauf mit dem
stück ist aber auch egal warum soll es
heute gar nicht primär gehen sondern um
den ender drachen und meine lieben
freunde habe ich in der letzten episode
gesagt schreibt mir mal bitte gern noch
mal und in die kommentare was sich
vielleicht vergessen habe was ich
vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen anders
machen sollte und da wurde mir
zuallererst mal geschrieben luca hol dir
einen wassereimer beziehungsweise den
raster ja schon aber packt den unten in
deine inventar leiste deswegen
wassereimer hier unten rein und das wenn
ich vom ende drachen hochgeschleudert
werde ich direkt schnell reagieren kann
es mir auch noch geschrieben oder war
luca das totem der unsterblichkeit bitte
auch unten in die leiste daher nehmen
wir auch das toten der unsterblichkeit
und nehmen das auch hier rein das kann
ich dann wenn ich f drücke ich das in
die hand nehmen und zwischen quasi mit
dem schild die sache ist allerdings dass
ich erst mal das schild in der hand
behalten werde weil ich am ende dann
auch einiges mit ender drachen et cetera
zu tun haben werde und meine lieben
freunde der letzte kommentar der mir
auch noch geschrieben wurde das büdchen
dass ich einfach mal hier stehen was mir
auch noch geschrieben wurde war luca die
axt hat einen sehr langen cool down at
schon wenn ich schlage wie langsam die
axt wieder hochgeht deswegen wird mir
auch geschrieben switch einfach mal so
ein bisschen durch nicht mal die achsen
im alter schwert guckt man mit wasser
besser klarkommt aber sonst waren
wirklich die meisten kommentare sich
relativ einig meisten kommentarschreiber
denn die meisten wirklich geschrieben
luca du bist wirklich gut vorbereitet
ich habe auch einen kommentar gelesen
irgendwann euch was ihr habt ihr noch
existiert da ging es also darum luca so
wie du ausgerüstet bist wird das ganze
entspannter als der bau folge wo ich mir
dachte ich bin immer noch luca
das jetzt so entspannt wird weiß ich
jetzt nicht hier laufen jetzt auf jeden
fall den berg runter
und gehen hier unten mit unserem hier
liegen noch so viele erdbrocken von dem
krieg glaube ich wir gehen jetzt auf
jeden fall hier unten runter in unserer
stronghold wir haben uns ja vor einigen
folgen hierunter gebaut um uns das ganze
schon mal anzugucken um generell erst
mal dass ein portal auf zu finden das
haben wir dann hier vorne gefunden und
jetzt muss ich ja hier klein bis hier
neben den umweg laufen einmal hier oben
lang dann hier um die seite hoch
hierdurch und dann sind wir hier vorne
auch schon in unserer kleinen revier in
unserer kleinen schlucht und haben dann
hier unser and portal
ok ich werde ganz kurz erstmal rechts
ins bett machen wir sind unten links
wiedereinstiegs punkt gesetzt das heißt
wenn ich sterben sollte werde ich hier
rauskommen und kann direkt wieder
reingehen ich möchte gar nicht mehr
lange drum herum reden meine lieben
freunde das ist das letzte mal
hoffentlich wenn ich in einer drachen
besiegen sollte das letzte mal dass wir
hier in unserer über welt stehen denn
jetzt jedes rein ins ende
den geschnitzten clubs habe ich auf wir
sind leider ein bisschen außerhalb
gesprochen haben hier unsere obsidian
plattform dort oben ist der ender drache
und ihr seht schon wenn ich mir angucke
passiert nichts also es hat alles
geklappt unsere aufgabe ist es nun diese
kristalle abzuschießen denn an diesen
kristallen seht ihr schon hängt der
ender drache dran und zieht sich damit
seine gesundheit deswegen werde ich mich
jetzt erstmal ganz entspannt darüber
bauen
was war das
[Musik]
caspers
was ist das
der ändert sache nicht abgeschlossen
oh
mein gott
was geht ab
branche ist habe ich die ganze zeit was
soll das das wusste ich nicht dass er da
so was kann ich habe auch schuster
durchzulaufen weil ich nicht weiß was
das ist ob das gift ist oder keine
ahnung was deswegen brauche ich mich
hier die ganze zeit drüber aber ich muss
einfach nur einmal auf die plattform den
händen kommen aber immer wenn ich ihn
schon höre habe ich schon oft direkt
wieder zu meinem sport nach vorne
allerdings haben wir es nun auch
geschafft und sind hier vorne auf der
richtigen insel angekommen ihr seht
schon ich kann die internet angucken das
klappt auf jeden fall perfekt mit dem
geschnitzten kürbissen mit dem texture
pack was ich mags dafür runter geladen
habe jetzt schnell auf die diamant
aktuelles wissen und erstmals ein
bisschen hier um gruppen erst mal ein
bisschen schauen um was es hier geht wir
haben nur um die teile die wir
abschließen müssen der ender drache lebt
sich die ganze da die energie auf und
das hier ist ein spot das heißt hier
müssen wir gleich angreifend dahin kehrt
er zu
[Musik]
wir sind allerdings direkt wieder hier
in unserem portal gesprochen und werden
direkt wieder zurück ins ende gehen und
wir sind auch nicht runtergefallen das
heißt unsere ganze zeit im sind noch
perfekter wie solche netze hochkommen
dass
dieses video ich bin immer dann gucken
dass ich mit minecraft auskennt
allerdings laufen wir jetzt schnell
wieder zurück über unsere kleine brücke
hier und schauen mal dass wir unsere
items wieder kriegen ich darf jetzt
keinen endermann hier angucken weil ich
ja nicht den geschnitzten kürbis gerade
auf dem kopf habe ich weiß nicht wo
genau der mich hin geschleudert hat das
war irgendwo da vorne oder so aber ich
glaube mal dass meine items noch da sein
sollten ja genau hier liegt auf jeden
fall als noch rum ich habe zwar nur noch
sieben level das ist mir aber erst mal
komplett egal erst mal die rüstung
anziehen und da vorne ist der ender
drache wir konzentrieren uns jetzt
erstmal darauf dass ich hier meinen
bogen nehme ich habe ja unendlichkeit
drauf und werde jetzt erstmal diese
teile ja abschießen
da kann ich ja gar nicht durch schießen
dann muss ich mich jetzt halt einfach an
der seite hoch bauen und das hier dann
einfach abbauen und dann kann ich auch
das ding glaube ich kaputt machten
perfekt okay der als kaputt ich bin euch
jetzt erstmal ganz schnell timeless
einen ich glaube so werde ich jetzt bei
jedem dieser ender kristalle vorgehen
okay ich bin fertig und habe alle von
diesen teilen abgebaut und abgeschossen
der ender drache kann sich nirgendwo
mehr sein leben ausfüllen das heißt ich
muss jetzt einfach nur warten und ihn
quasi abschießen und besiegen
wer nur gut wenn ich dann auch treffen
würde okay der änderten bewegt sich
wieder zu seinem sport das heißt ich
kann ihnen jetzt hier einfach schlagen
ich kann jetzt stehen bleiben
die ganze zeit schlagen und ihr seht
schon wie viel schaden das macht oben
der ändern
der ist richtig sauer auf den drachen
[Musik]
oh
mein gott
der ist
nicht so schwach der änderte
[Musik]
ich hab's geschafft
ich habe es geschafft
ich habe keine ahnung was das da hinten
ist was ich da gerade aufgebaut hat mit
diesem komischen laser
aber ich habe es geschafft
hier liegt unfassbar viel erfahrungen um
insgesamt habe ich jetzt schon unten die
in der leiste sehen könnt einfach nur
dadurch dass ich ihn getötet habe 63
level bekommen hier oben ist dabei ich
habe keine ahnung was das ist ich weiß
ich will nichts kaputt macht oder
irgendwas abbauen oder keine ahnung was
vielleicht bewegen wir uns ja irgendwann
folge 101 noch mal kurz rein und schauen
uns das an da wollen wir auch die
kommentare in lucka du musst eigentlich
nochmal danach ins ende weil es bauen
sich dann neue welten auf wenn du den
ender drachen besiegt hat und so weiter
und so fort allerdings habe ich mich
wohin die ganze zeit einfach auf den
fernkampf konzentriert und in dieser
armbrust hat mir wirklich den arsch
gerettet weil diese drei fälle fast
immer getroffen bei den bogen mit der
unendlichkeit hat richtig gut geholfen
ich habe fast keinen einzigen tränke
getrunken ich bin auch nicht noch mal
gestorben das tote meer und stetigkeit
musste ich einmal aktivieren das eine
aber das andere habe ich noch ich hab
dem motto mlg sprung einmal hingekriegt
aber ich habe jetzt gerade 15 minuten
lang auf den ende brachen eingeschossen
deswegen hab ich euch eine timeline
geblendet aber wir haben es geschafft
meine lieben freunde und das heißt das
projekt minecraft mit luca ist an der
stelle vorbei denn ich kann jetzt hier
in das and total springen
wir haben
minecraft
durchgespielt
[Musik]
ich hätte niemals gedacht dass
dieses projekt generell 100 folgen lang
gehen wird dass sich mehr als ein halbes
jahr am stück minecraft mal wieder auf
einem kanal hochladen und vor allem dass
wir da einen folge 101 ender drachen
besiegen werden und das ganze schaffen
werden
und das hätte ich niemals geschafft ohne
euch
ich hasse es wenn influenza die ganze
zeit sagen danke danke danke bla bla bla
und so heuchlerisch sind aber ich glaube
ich habe es in diesem projekt viel zu
wenig gesagt und es ist mir unfassbar
wichtig dass ihr wisst dass dieses
projekt nicht wegen mir oder wegen
meiner welt oder keine ahnung was so
cool war sondern nur wegen euch ohne
eure ganze hilfe in den kommentaren eure
vorschläge was ich bei unserer ohne eure
tipps beispielsweise wo ich mich
verlaufen mit dem kompass solche sachen
hatte ich nicht mehr meinem kopf und ich
habe meine kraft ganz lange nicht mehr
gespielt und es kam so viele neue sachen
dazu
und schlussendlich haben wir jetzt
geschafft
wir haben minecraft durchgespielt das
projekt minecraft mit luca 100 folgen
lang haben wir schwachsinn gemacht wir
hatten coole zeit werden traurige zeiten
ja die konstruktive zeit werden
produktive zeit aber wir hatten auch
manchmal einfach nur phasen wo einfach
nichts ging
ich habe mich aufgeregt ich hab gelacht
ich habe geweint ich habe es ist es war
eine achterbahn der gefühle die sich
über mehr als ein halbes jahr gezogen
hat und jetzt ist folge 100 vorbei
und ich hätte nicht gedacht dass wir das
schaffen werden heute
ich bin gestorben er hat eine lustige
momente werden auch heute wieder
traurige momente aber
schlussendlich sind wir am ziel
angekommen das ist das wichtigste wie
man dahin kommen dass scheiß egal
ob es jetzt jemand schafft in 20 minuten
ins ende zu kommen in minecraft mit
einer neuen welt und dann in einer
drachen mit leisen angst zu besiegen
oder ob ich 100 folgen brauche um mich
so ein bisschen verlaufe und verehre in
der schönheit von minecraft und das ein
oder andere gebäude noch bauer was
vielleicht auch dann schlussendlich
unnötig war und
[Musik]
ich glaube man braucht einfach nicht
mehr sagen als dass es eine wunderschöne
zeit weil die jetzt leider zu ende ist
aber man soll aufhören wenn es am
schönsten ist von daher meine lieben
freunde ich hoffe ich hatte diese volk
und das komplette projekt minecraft mit
lucca mindestens genau so viel spaß
gemacht wie mir etwas getan hat dann
würde ich mich unfassbar dollar über
einen daumen hoch von euch unter diesem
bier freuen wenn ihr meinen kanal und
klickt auf die glocke die staffel 2 mein
gott mit luca wenn sie denn irgendwann
starten sollte nicht verpassen wollte
ich kann euch noch nicht sagen ob es in
einer woche da sein wird oder in zwei
oder ob es der erst im november starten
wird
ich möchte jetzt erstmal ne kleine pause
gönnen
ich möchte ein bisschen das ganze revue
passieren lassen ich möchte
einfach diesem projekt auch den respekt
zollen den es verdient hat wie lässt
sich direkt morgen in der zweiten
staffel starten oder irgendwas anderes
machen ich hoffe ihr versteht das ich
bin euch unfassbar dankbar für alles
wenn ihr mir ein riesen gefallen tun
wollt dann schaut gern mal im luca -
shop.de vorbei und ist dieser vintage
herausgekommen und dieser blaue rudi
link dazu in der infobox meine lieben
freunde klickt einfach mal auf
lokalnews.de auf den link drauf oder
ladet euch jetzt gern die web runter
geht selber gerne reinem eine map
hinzieht ist auch und in der
beschreibung wenn ihr die welt von vorne
spielen wollte
[Musik]
ich könnte jetzt noch 20 minuten weiter
reden aber ich glaube
[Musik]
ich glaube ihr wisst was ich meine
wir kommen gerade damit sind die tränen
danke für alles generell nicht nur jetzt
bei diesem projekt sondern einfach
generell
ich habe dann auf jeden fall noch 20
minuten lang gewartet bis dieser
beschissenen abspann vorbei geht das
dann nicht einfach keinen bock mehr
seit 20 minuten läuft dieser abspann
jetzt ich wusste nicht mal dass
minecraft so viele pro user hat alltag
daneben klötzchen spiel
ich wollte eigentlich die folge jetzt
bleibt ihr machen habe ja gerade auch
gemacht und dann dass ich jetzt dann
daraus gehe und dann bin ich quasi
wieder am schwung holt dann fallen wir
zurück auf unsere insel und dann bin ich
da die folge aber mir hier seid ihr ziel
wieder zu lang ich muss das ganze ding
ja noch schneiden von daher ich weiß
nicht was hier passiert wenn ich jetzt
das ist jetzt nicht wahr
es ist jetzt nicht wahr
ich hätte einfach
können dann wäre es vorbei gewesen
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde wir sind wieder
hier vorne auf unserer kleinen insel
angekommen und ich werde mich jetzt
direkt online wächst hier
warum
jetzt war eingeläutet 2 max hirt
wieso kann nicht schlafen
das skelett hat sogar den pfeil
hochgeschossen
wie konnte ich dann jetzt schlafen gehen
aber gut ich glaube ich habe lange genug
geredet
und ihr wisst was ich euch mitteilen
möchte einfach nur danke
und damit möchte ich die heutige folge
jetzt auch beenden
wir sehen uns hat ein schuss